I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi. Is everybody ready for season eight? Season eight. Here it is. Ocho. We're doing it. The La Fon. That's sorry. That's Aitian and Denisha. Okay. No, I'm done. All right. Today is the list. It is season eight, episode one, written by BJ Novak, directed by BJ Novak. Angela, season eight was a very emotional roller coaster of a year for me
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士们。你好。嗨。大家都准备好迎接第八季了吗？第八季。它来了。第8季。我们开始吧。La Fon。对不起。那是Aitian和Denisha。好吧。不，我讲完了。好的。今天是这个名单。这是第八季第一集，由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，由BJ·诺瓦克执导。安吉拉，对我和《办公室》来说，
on The Office. First of all, I was very pregnant. Then I came back to work after only five weeks. Mm-hmm. And we didn't have Steve. It was a year. Yeah. It's really hard to go back to work when you have a baby. It just is. And there were some circumstances that made it harder, but we'll share about that when we get there. We'll get to that. Down the road, let's start this episode with a summary. Andy Bernard is our new Dunder Mifflin branch manager, and Robert California is the new CEO. He talked Saber. He talked Joe out of her own job. That made me laugh out loud. Yeah. In this episode, Aaron is going to discover that Robert California has made a list of employees in his notebook, and he has divided
第八季是充满情绪过山车的一年。首先，我怀孕很明显。然后仅仅五 weeks 后我又回去工作了。嗯哼。而且我们没有史蒂夫。这是漫长的一年。是的。当你有了孩子还要回去工作，真的很难。事实就是如此。有些情况让这变得更难，但等我们讲到那儿时，我们会分享的。我们会讲到那路的。展望未来，让我们以一个总结开始这一集。安迪·伯纳德是我们新的邓德米夫林分公司经理，而罗伯特·加利福尼亚是新任首席执行官。他谈到了佩伯。他游说乔放弃了自己的工作。这让我大声笑出来。是的。在这一集中，艾琳将发现在罗伯特·加利福尼亚的笔记本里有一份员工名单，他把
this list into two groups. But what do the groups mean? The Office makes it their mission to figure it out. Meanwhile, Angela got married to the state senator over the summer, and both Angela and Pam are pregnant. And Pam cannot stop crying. Pam, Pam was breaking my heart. Are you ready for FastFact number one? I am. Our FastFact number one is called new manager. That's right. Andy Bernard, how did this all come about? Well, as I said before, there was no decision about who was going to take over as manager when we ended season seven. We all left for our summer break. We didn't know. We had no idea. It was a very interesting summer for our writers. And thanks to many messages that I exchanged with BJ
这份名单分成了两组。但是这两组意味着什么呢？《办公室》把弄清楚这件事当作了他们的使命。与此同时，安吉拉在夏天嫁给了州参议员，安吉拉和帕姆都怀孕了。而且帕姆眼泪止不住地流。帕姆，帕姆让我心碎。你准备好迎接冷知识第一条了吗？我准备好了。我们的冷知识第一条叫做“新经理”。没错，安迪·伯纳德，这一切是怎么发生的？好吧，正如我之前所说，当第七季结束时，谁将接任经理并没有做出决定。我们都去过暑假了。我们不知道。我们完全不知道。对于我们的编剧来说，这是一个非常有趣的夏天。多亏了我与BJ
Novak and Paul Lieberstein, and from reading Andy Green's book and doing some Googling, I have the dish on how it all came about. Oh, give it to us. All right. The first debate was outside hire versus inside hire. This debate, I remember well, it was swirling around for a while. Well, the general consensus was inside hire. Yeah. However, the network liked the idea of an outside hire. So our writers did entertain this idea. And the biggest name being tossed around was James Gandolfini. I remember this, Gemma. You do? Yeah, I do. I remember too. Paul Lieberstein, BJ Novak and Danny Chun all met with James Gandolfini about coming in as our new manager. And in Andy Green's book, which by the way is called
诺瓦克和保罗·利伯斯坦交流的许多消息，以及通过阅读安吉·格林的书并进行了一些谷歌搜索，我对这一切是如何发生的有了独家内幕。哦，快告诉我们吧。好的。第一场辩论是外部聘用与内部聘用。这场辩论，我记得很清楚，它流传了好一阵子。嗯，大家的普遍共识是内部聘用。是的。然而，电视网喜欢外部聘用的想法。所以我们的编剧确实考虑了这个想法。流传最广的名字是詹姆斯·甘多菲尼。我记得这个，珍娜。你记得？是的，我记得。我也记得。保罗·利伯斯坦、BJ·诺瓦克和丹尼·陈都与詹姆斯·甘多菲尼会面，讨论他加入我们担任新经理的事。在安吉·格林的书里，顺便说一句，这本书叫做
the office, the untold story of the greatest sitcom of the 2000s, Danny Chun shared that James had seen a few episodes of the show and he was very complimentary and very interested. BJ Novak told me that when they met with him, he was super nervous because James Gandolfini was his favorite actor. And he said that James Gandolfini was pretty shy during the meeting. But also, BJ and Paul and Danny were very shy as well. And so it was a very quiet meeting. Nobody said very much. They just kind of sat there. We were all obsessed with the Sopranos. Let me tell you, if Tony Soprano had walked onto that, that soundstage, I would have been like, All right. So here's the character that they had in mind. This is how Danny described
《办公室：2000年代最伟大情景喜剧的未讲故事》，丹尼·陈分享说詹姆斯看过该剧的几集，他非常赞赏并且非常感兴趣。BJ·诺瓦克告诉我，当他们与他会面时，他超级紧张，因为詹姆斯·甘多菲尼是他最喜欢的演员。他说詹姆斯·甘多菲尼在会面时相当害羞。而且，BJ、保罗和丹尼也很害羞。所以这是一次非常安静的会面。没有谁说很多话。他们只是坐在那里。我们都对《黑道家族》痴迷。让我告诉你，如果托尼·瑟普拉诺走进那个摄影棚，我会觉得，好吧。所以这是他们脑海中的角色。丹尼是这样描述
it. Quote, salt of the earth, intense, passionate guy who could be your father figure and your biggest supporter and the most sort of wonderful person to have on your side, but also turn around and be the scariest person you've ever seen in your life and just bite your head off about something. So this was the character they were imagining that James Gandolfini would play in a comedic way. This was a comic turn. But ultimately, it didn't work out. Now, there was a little dish served up recently on the podcast, Talking Sopranos. That is the podcast where the stars of the Sopranos, it's Michael Imperioli and Steve Sharipa. They tell stories about Sopranos. Yeah. Everyone, you should listen if you want to hear some
它的。原话：“脚踏实地、热情、充满激情的人，可以成为你的大家长、你最大的支持者、在你这边最美妙的人，但也会转过身来成为你一生中见过最吓人的人，为了某事对你大发雷霆。”所以这就是他们想象詹姆斯·甘多菲尼会以喜剧方式扮演的角色。这是一次喜剧转型。但最终，它没有成功。现在，最近在播客《讨论黑道家族》上透露了一些内幕。那是《黑道家族》明星们的播客，由迈克尔·因佩里奥利和史蒂夫·希里帕主持。他们讲述《黑道家族》的故事。是的。大家，如果你想听一些关于《黑道家族》的剖析，你应该听听。但他们谈到了詹姆斯·甘多菲尼可能加入《办公室》的这个时刻，
breakdown about the Sopranos. But they talked about this moment where James Gandolfini was possibly going to come on the office. And Steve Sharipa said, we made him an offer, but that HBO countered our offer and paid him $3 million not to take the role. Geez. Yeah. Now, I did some fact checking on that. My sources tell me that we never made a financial offer to James Gandolfini. At least you're a secret source. These are my secret sources. But that James Gandolfini ultimately decided that he wanted to do a development deal with HBO and do some other projects rather than get locked into a TV contract. So I guess HBO did make him a deal. Yeah. Maybe that stopped any potential deal in its tracks with
史蒂夫·希里帕说，我们向他提出了报价，但HBO反报价，付给他300万美元让他不要接受这个角色。天哪。是的。现在，我对此进行了事实核查。我的消息来源告诉我，我们从未向詹姆斯·甘多菲尼发出过金钱报价。至少你的秘密来源是这样的。这些是我的秘密来源。但詹姆斯·甘多菲尼最终决定与HBO达成开发协议并进行其他项目，而不是被锁在电视合同里。所以我想HBO确实和他达成了一笔交易。是的。也许这把我们之间任何潜在的交易扼杀在了摇篮里。但我的消息来源称，官方并没有发出过报价。好吧。所以在这一切之后，编剧们确定我们要进行内部聘用。那是他们最初的直觉。没错。来自伊利诺伊州艾伦代尔的克里斯塔·迪说，
us. But my sources say an offer was not officially made. Okay. So after all of this, the writers decided for sure we're going to do an inside hire. That had been their first instinct. Right. Christa Dee from Allendale, Illinois said, did the writers choose Andy to become the Scranton Branch Manager because he's the most likely to be a yes man to corporate? Was there a lot of discussion around who would take over as manager? Oh, Christa. There was so much discussion. There was lots of chatter. Writer Danny Chun said the discussions got quite heated. Paul Lieberstein said, here was their criteria for picking a new boss. Quote, one of the important aspects is that the boss puts something into the relationships
编剧们选择安迪成为斯克兰顿分公司经理是因为他最有可能对公司唯命是从吗？关于谁将接管经理职位，有很多讨论吗？哦，克里斯塔。有太多的讨论了。有很多闲聊。编剧丹尼·陈说讨论变得相当激烈。保罗·利伯斯坦说，这是他们挑选新老板的标准。原话：“一个重要的方面是老板在办公室的关系中投入了不仅仅是职业层面的东西。他们必须将其视为远超于此的东西。”他们决定最个人化地承担经理工作的两个人是安迪或德怀特。好吧。这说得通。人们为每一方进行了激烈的辩论。如果你想阅读每个人对此的热情感受，都在安吉·格林的书里。安吉·格林的书里有很多东西就像我早就知道的那样，就像我们知道的那样。
in the office that is not just professional. They have to see it as a lot more than what it is. And they decided that the two people who would take the job of manager most personally were Andy or Dwight. Okay. That tracks. People argued heavily for each side. If you want to read everyone's passionate feelings about this, it is all in Andy Green's book. There's a lot of stuff in Andy Green's book that like I knew already, like we knew. Right. Right. This was a glimpse into the writer's room that I found very interesting. So just putting that out there. So maybe the real list was a notepad and on one side was Andy and on the other side was Dwight. Oh, yeah. I think you're right. Oh, yeah. I remember Paul called
没错。没错。我觉得这是一个非常有趣的对编剧室的窥探。所以只是顺便提一下。所以也许真正的名单是一个记事本，一边是安迪，另一边是德怀特。哦，是的。我想你是对的。哦，是的。我记得保罗把我叫进他的办公室，问我的意见。我以为应该是安迪还是德怀特？我说德怀特。对不起，埃德。我真的很希望德怀特得到它。你知道，德怀特这个角色渴望这个太久了。我想我是想为他实现那个梦想。是的。所以我选了德怀特。以下是他们的一些担忧。他们的担忧是让德怀特担任经理意味着我们会失去主要的对手。没错。
me into his office and he asked me my opinion. Did I think it should be Andy or Dwight? I said Dwight. I'm sorry, Ed. I just really wanted it for Dwight. You know, the character of Dwight has wanted this for so long. I think I wanted that dream fulfillment for him. Yeah. So I picked Dwight. Here were a couple of their concerns. Their concern was that having Dwight as the manager meant that we would lose our main antagonist. Right. Right. That is fair. And you would lose that foil between Jim and Dwight because now Dwight would be Jim's boss. Yes. Yeah. But they were also concerned that the character of Andy becoming manager would feel too similar to Michael Scott. And it would be harder to distinguish
没错。这很公平。而且你会失去吉姆和德怀特之间的那种针锋相对，因为现在德怀特将成为吉姆的老板。是的。是的。但他们也担心安迪成为经理的角色会让人觉得太像迈克尔·斯科特。而且很难将他与迈克尔区分开来。他们正试图想通这一点。嗯，就在这个时候，《宿醉2》上映了，票房收入超过5亿美元。这太巨大了。我的意思是，这把埃德 catapulted 到了一个全新的星际水平，比如，我不知道，演艺界。嗯，你猜怎么着？在那之后，电视网有一种非常强烈的直觉。我打赌他们有。而这让天平倾向于埃德接管这个角色。冷知识第二条。你准备好听这个内幕了吗？是的。
him from Michael. And they were trying to wrap their head around that. Well, right around this time, the Hangover 2 came out and it earned over $500 million at the box office. This was so huge. I mean, it catapulted Ed into this whole new stratosphere of like, I don't know, show biz. Well, guess what? The network had a real strong feeling about it after that. I bet they did. And that tipped the scales in favor of Ed taking over the role. Fastback number two. Are you ready for this dish? Yeah. This one is called New CEO. Fan question from Makayla G in Wisconsin. In this episode, James Bader takes over the role of CEO for Kathy Bates. Is there a reason why they had James Bader join the cast instead
这个叫做“新CEO”。来自威斯康星州的麦凯拉·G的粉丝提问。在这一集中，詹姆斯·贝德接替凯西·贝茨担任CEO的角色。他们让詹姆斯·贝德加入演员阵容而不是让凯西·贝茨继续担任CEO，有什么原因吗？是的，麦凯拉。凯西·贝茨接拍了一部名为《律政俏律师》（Harry's Law）的新电视剧，她是主角。她没空当我们的CEO。她是哈里吗？就像她的姓是哈利吗？我不知道。嗯，如果她是这部《律政俏律师》的主角，我完全不知道。抱歉，我只是好奇。好的，卡茜刚刚说《律政俏律师》里，哈里是哈里特的简称。好吧。所以我们不再有CEO了。我们需要一个新的CEO。发生了一件这样的事。在夏天，人们对罗伯特·加利福尼亚这个角色疯狂了。
of keeping Kathy Bates as the CEO? Yes, Makayla. Kathy Bates landed on a new TV series she was the star of called Harry's Law. She was not available to be our CEO. Was she Harry? Like was her last name Harry? I don't know. Well, if she's the star in this Harry's Law, I have no idea. Sorry, I'm just curious. Okay, Cassie just said that Harry's Law, Harry is short for Harriet. All right. So we don't have a CEO anymore. We need a new CEO. Here's something that happened. Over the summer, people freaked out over the character of Robert California. As they should. Yes. He is delicious. The head of the network love James Bader. The writers love James Bader. He was an audience favorite. They were like, maybe James Bader
他们理应如此。是的。他太美味了。电视网负责人喜欢詹姆斯·贝德。编剧们喜欢詹姆斯·贝德。他是观众的最爱。他们想，也许詹姆斯·贝德可以成为我们的新CEO。他们不知道是否能说服他这样做。当他们向他推销客串时，这是一件大事。他们说，别担心。只是一集。只是一件事。你进出一下就行了。事实证明，他喜欢拍我们的节目。他有一段很棒的经历，但他接受这个角色的另一个原因，在安吉·格林的书里被揭露了。天哪，太惊艳了。我太爱詹姆斯·贝德了。他说他接这个角色是因为他喜欢这个节目，也因为他基本上破产了，需要钱。他说，这太像他了。我能听到他这么说。他说他刚对房子进行了一次大翻修，花光了他所有的《波士顿法律》的钱。
could be our new CEO. They didn't know if they could convince him to do it. It was like a big thing when they pitched him the cameo. They're like, don't worry. It's one episode. It's one thing. You'll be in and out. Turns out he loved doing our show. He had a great experience, but there was another reason why he accepted the role, which was revealed in Andy Green's book. And oh my God, it is amazing. I love James Bader so much. He said he took the role because he liked the show and also because he was basically broke and needed the money. He said, this is so him. I can hear him saying this. He said he'd just done a big renovation on his house and he'd spent all of his Boston legal money. He needed the
伙计们，他需要这张支票。是的。他还在百老汇演了一整年的话剧，正如我们所知，那并不赚多少钱。他是这么说的，当话剧演完时，原话：“我知道我需要一些钱，因为演话剧让我现金流失严重。然后突然我接到了《办公室》的电话。”现在我们最初打电话给他只是为了在节目中做一个客串演出，就像凯西·贝茨那样不时露面。但当时他也在洽谈出演史蒂夫·斯皮尔伯格的电影《林肯》，他真的很想演。而且看起来会有冲突。他说他们拍电影《林肯》的预算真的很缩减。那不会是一张大支票，而且电影要八个月后才开拍。他说他真的希望你知道，原话：“到这个时候，我已经破产了。真的，我破产了。”
paycheck guys. Yeah. He'd also just done a play on Broadway for a whole year, which as we know, does not pay a lot. And he said this, when the play was done, quote, I knew I was going to need some money because I was hemorrhaging cash doing the play. And then all of a sudden I got a call from the office. Now we initially called him about just doing an arc on the show, just kind of like popping in from time to time like Kathy Bates had done. But at the time he was also in talks to do the Steven Spielberg movie Lincoln, which he really wanted to do. And it seemed like it was going to be a conflict. He said they were doing the movie Lincoln on a really reduced budget. It was not going to be a big
所以他告诉他的经纪人回到《办公室》说他会演这个角色一年，但必须是完整的一季。如果《林肯》电影拍成了，他需要请假去拍电影。他需要赚那笔钱。听着，珍和我在笑，因为我能听到他的声音。他说某些事时不能太认真，就好像这个人不会撒谎。他只是确切地告诉你他的想法。这些话让我微笑，因为这就是我们喜欢在片场和他们在一起的那个詹姆斯·贝德。是的，他就是没有废话。不，直截了当。我就是很喜欢他。我也是。所以事情就这样成了。詹姆斯·贝德得到了这个角色。嗯，我在2011年7月6日的《娱乐周刊》上看到了一篇文章，保罗·利伯斯坦被问到关于詹姆斯接任CEO的事。他是这么说的：
paycheck and the movie wasn't going to start for eight months. And he said he really wanted you to know, quote, by this point, I was broke. Really, I was broke. So he told his agents to go back to the office and say he would do the part for one year, but it had to be for a full season. And he needed time off to do the movie Lincoln if it came together. He needed to get that coin. Listen, Jen and I are laughing because I can hear his voice. I can't do so earnest when he says something that it's like the man cannot lie. He just tells you exactly his thoughts. The quotes made me smile because it was the same James Bader that we loved being on set with. Yeah, he is just no BS. No, straightforward. I
詹姆斯将再次扮演罗伯特·加利福尼亚，这位超级推销员有能力像一个高级怪胎绝地武士一样去说服和操纵。他在夏天被聘为新经理，但在几小时内就让自己晋升了。几天之内，他就接管了公司。詹姆斯有一种完全属于他自己的能量，而办公室没有任何工具来对付这家伙。我们很高兴他加入我们的演员阵容。我喜欢。我们当时也是，我们太兴奋了。我有太多的故事。我们有太多的故事。我们在我们的书《办公室闺蜜》里，你们这些家伙，分享了一些我们在化妆间和詹姆斯在一起的早晨。你准备好迎接冷知识第三条了吗？是的，它叫做“大孕妇，小孕妇”。是的，因为我们很高兴能一起有这条故事线。
just loved him. Same. So it worked out. James Bader got the role. Well, I came across an article in Entertainment Weekly from July 6, 2011, and Paul Lieberstein was asked about James taking over as CEO. And this is what he said. James will reprise his role as Robert California, the Uber salesman that has a power to convince and manipulate like a high class weirdo Jedi warrior. He'll have been hired over the summer as the new manager, but within hours gets himself promoted. Within days, he takes over the company. James has an energy that is completely his own and the office has no tools for dealing with this guy. We are thrilled he's joining our cast. I love it. And we were, we were so excited. I have
你还记得剧本围读吗？记得，我们当时欣喜若狂，珍娜，我找到了我发给史蒂夫关于这件事的电子邮件。什么？是的，在我的数字杂物中。你一定要听听这个。嘿，史蒂夫，你们好吗？恭喜你们获得艾美奖提名。好吧，首先，你们实至名归。但自私地说，我们太兴奋了，因为这意味着我们可以见到你们。这周，我们回到了第八季。他们为帕姆和安吉拉准备了一些非常有趣的故事线。我们再次成为了真正的死对头。珍娜和我都超级兴奋。很多感叹号。另外，你应该知道珍娜超级可爱而且怀孕非常明显。她要生一个男宝宝了，伊莎贝尔还是那么厚脸皮。希望你们一切都好，孩子们也很棒。
so many stories. We have so many stories. We share some in our book, The Office BFFs you guys, about our mornings in here and makeup with James. Are you ready for Fast Fact number three? Yes, it's called Big Preggs, Little Preggs. Yes, because we were so excited to have this storyline together. Do you remember the table read? Yes, we were giddy and Jenna, I found an email I sent to Steve about it. What? Yes, in my digital clutter. You have to hear this. Hey, Steve, how are you guys? Congrats on your Emmy nomination. Okay, first of all, you so deserve it. But selfishly, we are so excited because it means we get to see you guys. This week, we went back for season eight. They have some really fun story
另外，我还在为我该死的洒水器烦恼。当然，每当它们坏了，我就会想起你和南茜大笑。因为我会一直和他谈论我的房主之类的问题。但是，女士们，我们太兴奋了。我喜欢你对此如此兴奋，以至于你把它写在了发给史蒂夫的电子邮件更新里，你会这么做，这是最贴心的事情。我知道他很喜欢，因为他可以稍微一窥事情的进展。是的。他总是会回复他们最近在忙什么。你知道我们对史蒂夫的感觉。他就是最棒的。嗯，我写了一篇MySpace博客来开启这个新季度。以下是我关于大孕妇、小孕妇所写的内容。老掉牙的MySpace博客。是的。我说，原话：
lines for Pam and Angela. We get to be real frenemies again. And Jenna and I are so excited. Very exclamation marks. Also, you should know Jenna is so adorable and very pregnant. She's going to have a baby boy and Isabel is as sassy as they come. I hope you all are well and the kiddos are great. Also, I'm still having problems with my damn sprinklers. And of course, I think of you and Nancy laughing whenever they break. Because I would talk to him all the time about my homeowner like issues. But lady, we were so excited. I love that you were so excited about it that you put it in your little email update to Steve, which you would do, which was the sweetest thing. And I know he loved because he would
“现在我真的怀孕了，我可以带着极大的权威报道说，真正的怀孕比穿着那些假肚子12小时要好得多。”可怜的安吉拉。她终于明白我在抱怨什么了。那些假肚子会勒进你的膀胱。所以你不得不一直上厕所，而且你必须把衣服完全脱光才能去洗手间，因为它们就像在所有衣服下面穿了一件小潜水衣。而且你会流汗。太糟糕了。真搞笑。安吉拉终于有了一个闺蜜，可以和她聊聊真正的怀孕。而我终于有了一个闺蜜，可以和她聊聊假怀孕。这是真的。这是真的。这就是我们把所有人都搞糊涂的那一年。这一年，我们的剧本主管瓦达大声说，等一下，到底谁是真的怀孕，谁又是假怀孕？因为我们刚刚对调了。
get a little glimpse into how things were going. Yes. And he always would respond back to what they were up to. You know how we feel about Steve. He's just the best. Well, I wrote a MySpace blog to kick off this new season. And here is what I wrote about our big pregs, little pregs. Ye olde MySpace blog. Yes. I said, quote, now that I'm actually pregnant, I can report with much authority that real pregnancy is way better than wearing one of those fake bellies for 12 hours a day. Poor Angela. She finally understands what I'd been complaining about. Those fake bellies cut into your bladder. So you have to pee all the time and you have to get totally undressed to use the restroom because they're like wearing
是的。好吧，女士，你猜怎么着？这段时间我们像疯了一样发邮件。你准备好了解一些更多的数字杂物了吗？请吧。以下是我们互相发送的邮件的几个主题标题。好的。从你到我。主题标题。Bundle me 汽车座椅套。想法。这是你发给我的下一封邮件。奶瓶。点，点，点。你发给我的下一封邮件是托儿所壁画问号。然后你发给我，婴儿床还是便携游戏床，为了你的房车。然后我发给你。这是我的吸奶器。换尿布垫和换尿布垫套。有机婴儿店。你的迎婴派对。点，点，点。我们有很多关于你怀孕的通信。你在筑巢，我很高兴终于能和你分享这个新手妈妈的对话。
a little wetsuit under all of your clothes. And you sweat. It's awful. It's funny. Angela finally has a BFF who she can talk to about real pregnancy. And I finally have a BFF that I can talk to about fake pregnancy. And it was true. It was true. And this is the year we confused everyone. This is the year our script supervisor, Vada, said out loud, wait, who's real pregnant and who's fake pregnant again? Because we just had flip flopped. Yes. Well, lady, guess what? We were emailing like crazy during this time. Are you ready for some more digital clutter? Please. Here are just a few of the subject titles that we emailed each other. Okay. From you to me. Subject title. Bundle me car seat covers.
哦，天哪。我记得这一切。这一切都把我带回去了。我知道。好吧，这就是我所有的冷知识了。当我们回来时，我们将有一个非常美味的平板支撑开场白，我为此准备了一些有趣的东西。我知道你也是。哦，我确实有。我想也许今天我可以试着做平板支撑。什么？好吧，你上次做平板支撑是什么时候？或者你做过平板支撑吗？我的意思是，我在瑜伽课上做平板支撑，但是它，你知道的，我用我的手做平板支撑。好的，炫耀狂。但珍娜瑜伽其实做得很好。你们这些家伙。好吧，让我们休息一下，然后我们来讨论关于平板支撑的所有事情，我想是的。我们回来了，这一集将从奥斯卡走过艾琳开始。看起来她趴在地上，但他立刻知道她在做平板支撑。
Thoughts. Here's the next email you sent me. Baby bottles. Dot, dot, dot. The next email you sent me was nursery mural question mark. Then you sent me crib or pack and play for your trailer. Then I sent you. Here's my breast pump. Changing pads and changing pad covers. Organic baby store. Your baby shower. Dot, dot, dot. We had a lot of correspondence about your pregnancy. You were nesting and I was so excited to finally be able to share this new mom. Just conversation with you. Oh my gosh. I remember all of that. All of that takes me back. I know. Well, that's all I have for fast facts. When we come back, we have a very delicious planking cold open and I've got some fun stuff for that. And I know you do
她说，哦，天哪。她趴在那个防止你的车撞到建筑物的混凝土上。她甚至不在地上。那个混凝土像减速带一样的东西。是的。我的意思是，她其实不在。有一个类似蕨类植物的垫子。什么？蕨类植物垫。什么是蕨类植物垫？我们讨论过蕨类植物垫。还记得我和史蒂夫在屋顶上抓住蕨类植物垫的经历吗，当格雷格坐在蕨类植物垫上的时候，女士。她躺在那个混凝土东西上。她不是真的躺在上面。是的，她是。不，他们在那上面放了点东西，她躺在那上面。他们没有。他们放了。他们没有。你怎么知道？因为那会太痛苦了。她做到了。我要给埃利发短信。我向你保证，他们在那儿放了一个你看不见的小垫子。
too. Oh, I do. And I thought maybe today I'd try to plank. What? Well, when's the last time you planked? Or have you ever planked? I mean, I plank in yoga class, but it, you know, I'm using my planking with my hands. Okay, Braggie. But Jenna's actually really good at yoga. You guys. Well, let's take a break and then we will discuss all things planking, I guess. We are back and this episode is going to start with Oscar walking past Erin. It looks like she's laying on the ground, but he knows immediately she's planking. She's like, Oh, good Lord. She's laying on that cement thing that keeps your car from hitting the building. She's not even on the ground. The concrete like bumper thing. Yes.
我向你保证他们没有。珍娜，你试过躺在混凝土梁上吗？是的。压碎你的胸部和胯部。那会很痛苦。那会夹在你的胸部中间。哎哟。然后你的额头靠着。我发誓。我发誓。还有你的骨盆骨。好的。大家，请稍等。我们没有预料到这一点。绝对不可能。名单剖析的巨大辩论。埃利是躺在蕨类植物垫上还是仅仅是混凝土减速带上？有一些缓冲。我告诉你。好的。暂停。暂停。当我和她发短信时，我们会继续剖析，一等她回我短信，我们就告诉你。好的。好的。我想重新看开头并放大。你的电话已被转接到自动语音留言系统。嗨，埃利。我是珍娜。嗨，埃利。我是安吉。
I mean, she's not really. There was like a ferny pad. A what? A ferny pad. What's a ferny pad? We've talked about ferny pads. Remember my ferny pad catch on the roof with Steve when Greg was sitting on a ferny pad lady. She's laying on that concrete thing. She's not really laying on it. Yes, she is. No, they put something on there that she laid on. They did not. They did. They didn't. How do you know? Because it'd be too painful. She did it. I'm going to text Ellie. I guarantee you they put a little patty thingy there that you couldn't see. I guarantee you they did not. Jenna, have you tried to lay on a like cement beam? Yes. Smoosh your boobs and your crotch. It would be painful. It would go between
我们正在重温第八季，那一集是《名单》，你在停车场做平板支撑，你躺在混凝土减速带类似的东西上。现在，我们这里有了一场辩论。我认为你是直接躺在混凝土减速带上的。我认为有什么蕨类植物垫之类的东西，所以你没有把自己压在一块细细的混凝土上。谁是对的，埃利？如果你想的话，你可以给我们回短信。我们在录播客，但我们需要你在这里发表意见。好的。爱你的。拜拜。这些就是现在人们从我们这里得到的留言。奥斯卡将有一个访谈，他说平板支撑又愚蠢又危险。这是一种新潮流，人们躺在奇怪的地方，而且，你知道，有时会被车碾过。谢谢，互联网。我简单深入了解了一下平板支撑的历史。平板支撑还有历史吗？
your boobs. Ow. And then your forehead is resting. I swear. I swear. And your pelvis bone. Okay. Everybody, one moment. We were not expecting this. There is no way. The great debate of the list breakdown. Was Ellie laying on a ferny pad or just the concrete bumper? There was some buffer. I am telling you. Okay. Pause. Pause. While I text her, we'll keep breaking down and as soon as she texts me back, we'll let you know. Okay. Okay. I want to rewatch the beginning and zoom in. Your call has been forwarded to an automatic voice message system. Hi, Ellie. It's Jenna. Hi, Ellie. It's Ange. We're rewatching season eight, the episode, the list where you're planking in the parking lot and you're laying on like the concrete
有。关于谁发明了平板支撑存在争议。什么？是的。所以在2011年，当我们拍摄这一集时，平板支撑的潮流，即躺在奇怪的地方然后发布自己的照片，变得非常流行。获得发起这场病毒式轰动功劳的人...我可以猜吗？我可以猜吗？当然。他是法国人吗？他是澳大利亚人。他是一个名叫萨姆·韦克斯特的木匠，他为平板支撑创建了一个Facebook群组，这被认为是启动这一切的功臣。韦克斯特说，“平板支撑”这个词是他和他的两个朋友在2008年夏天创造的，他说他们当时在一个酒吧里，在地上做蠕虫舞。然后其中一个人突然停下来一动不动，每个人都觉得这真的很有趣。
bumper thing. Now, we're having a debate here. I think you laid directly on the concrete bumper. I think there was like some kind of ferny pad, so you weren't smooshing yourself on a piece of like skinny concrete. Who's right, Ellie? You can just text us back if you want. We're doing the podcast, but we need you to weigh in here. Okay. Love you. Bye. Bye. These are the kind of messages people give from us now. Oscar is going to have a talking head where he says planking is stupid and dangerous. It's a new trend where people lay in weird places and, you know, sometimes get run over. Thanks, internet. I did a mini deep dive on the history of planking. There's a history of planking. There is a controversy over who invented planking.
这就拉开了序幕。然后他们开始在其他地方做那个动作，并称之为平板支撑。我的意思是，这听起来确实像是某个在酒吧度过的夜晚产物。我的意思是，当然，对吧？就像，我买账。听起来不错。好吧，Facebook页面变得非常流行，然后媒体抓住了它，但英国有一些人并不买账。他们说他们在2007年就创建了一个Facebook页面，特色是以有趣的方式躺在物体上的人。这个页面的创始人，他的名字叫加里·克拉克森。他被引述说：“我觉得很有趣，澳大利亚人制作了一个游戏和一个Facebook群组，和我的一模一样，并开始声称是他发明的。”哦，那是英国内部的一点讽刺。克拉克森说他和他的朋友
What? Yes. So in 2011, when we made this episode, the trend of planking, of laying down in odd places and then posting a photo of yourself had become really popular. The person who gets credit for starting this viral sensation... Can I guess? Can I guess? Sure. Are they French? They're Australian. He's a carpenter named Sam Weckert, and he started a Facebook page group for planking, and that is credited with kick starting things. Weckert said that the term planking was coined by himself and his two friends back in the summer of 2008, he said that they were in a bar and they were like doing the worm on the ground. And then one of them just stopped and was still, and everybody thought that was really funny. And that kind of started it. And then they started
发明了它。他们称之为“躺下游戏”。好吧，你的问题来了。你得有一个吸引人的名字。你可能发明了它。这可能是真的。我不是来反驳这一点的，但是加里，你得弄一个吸引人的名字。是的，那才是吸引人的地方。第一。现在回到奥斯卡的话题，有人在做平板支撑时受伤了，还有一个人死了。哦，他们试图在七楼阳台的栏杆上做平板支撑，然后摔了下去。哦，天哪，太可怕了。是的，各位。大家在那儿要小心。是的，安全地做平板支撑，拜拜。电梯要打开了，站在那里的是安迪和德怀特。安迪要说他让德怀特做他的老二。当他说出这话时，我真的好伤心。我知道德怀特一直是老二。
doing that in other places and called it planking. I mean, it does sound like something that came out of a night at a bar. I mean, for sure, right? Like, I'm buying that. That sounds good. Well, the Facebook page became really popular and then the media got ahold of it, but there are some folks in England who are not having it. They said that they started a Facebook page in 2007, featuring people laying down on objects in funny ways. And the founder of this page, his name is Gary Clarkson. He was quoted as saying this little Gary sass quote, I find it funny how the Australian makes a game and a Facebook group exactly the same as ours and starts claiming he invented it. Oh, that's a little internal UK sass. Clarkson said that he and his friend
一直是老二。德怀特有一个访谈，他说，你知道吗，我一开始很失望，但我现在挺好的。他在练空手道、拳击、自由搏击、以色列格斗术和冥想。你知道吗，他过得挺好的。是的。现在我们要发现帕姆怀上了小迈克尔·斯科特。吉姆不喜欢那个玩笑。说出来。他说，别再说了。好吧，帕姆说，你知道吗，她其实很高兴。她不是办公室里唯一的孕妇。这切换到了我最喜欢的访谈之一。而且，帕姆和安吉拉从来没有做过联合访谈。所以你和我作为朋友超级兴奋。你注意到访谈的位置了吗？是的。窗户在我们身后。是的。我想我们需要听听这个。哦，是的。
invented it. They called it the laying down game. Well, here's your problem. You got to have a catchy name. You might have invented it. That might be true. I'm not here to contest that, but Gary, you got to get a catchy name. Yeah, that's what catches on. One. Now to Oscar's point, people have been injured planking and one person died. Oh, they tried to plank on the railing of a seventh floor balcony and they fell off. Oh my gosh, that's horrible. Yes, everyone. Be careful out there. Yeah, plank safely, please. Well, the elevator is going to open and standing there are Andy and Dwight. Andy is going to say that he's making Dwight his number two. When he said that, I just got so sad. I know Dwight's always
看，小孕妇和大孕妇。等等，我们是什么时候开始的？我们俩的体型差距不是很惊人吗？嗯，我比你早几个月。我和我的丈夫，也就是参议员，有一个孩子，而帕姆和吉姆有一个孩子。伟大的推销员。我喜欢伟大的推销员。我对那句台词的看法是。我认为安吉拉实际上是在努力表现得友善。她是，这是她试图给帕姆赞美的一种被动攻击的方式。是的。哦，好吧。我在这场访谈中有一个背景彩蛋。是什么？你注意到安吉拉的指甲是亮红色的吗？没有。她什么时候涂过红指甲油？哦。从来没有。这就像是一些真正辛辣的东西。好吧，我在我的数字杂物中查到，我们拍摄这一集的那个星期，我还在拍摄《闪电击中》。
number two. Always the number two. Dwight has a talking head where he says, you know what, I was disappointed at first, but I'm doing fine. He's doing karate and boxing and kickboxing and crab McGaw and meditation. And you know what, he's doing just great. Yes. Now we're going to find out that Pam is pregnant with little Michael Scott. Jim doesn't like that joke. Say that. He says, stop saying that. Well, Pam says, you know what, she's actually happy. She's not the only pregnant woman in the office. This cuts to one of my favorite talking heads. Also, Pam and Angela never do joint talking heads. So you and I as friends were so excited. Did you notice where the talking head was located? Yes. With the windows behind us. Yeah. I think we need to hear it. Oh,
哦，哇。这周我在两个片场之间来回奔跑，我在《闪电击中》中的角色有指甲油和这个高高的发型，我给你发了邮件，珍娜，因为我说了这个，我不敢相信有一天我戴着假肚子，然后我去了下一个片场，我戴着假屁股。这一周全是假肚子，假屁股，假肚子，假屁股，因为我在《闪电击中》里的角色，导演希望她有一个大一点的臀部，他们有一个我必须穿的垫臀西装。这疯狂吗？你花了那么多时间在那些潜水衣垫子服装里。是的，对我来说这是非常有趣的一周，因为我来回奔跑，但我想对于这次访谈，我忘记把指甲油卸掉了。好吧，安吉拉，我们收到了一个关于你的粉丝提问，来自安娜在斯克兰顿的提问。
yes. Look, it's a little pregs and big pregs. Wait, when did we start? Isn't it amazing the difference in our sizes? Well, I am a few months ahead of you. I'm having a child with my husband, the senator, and Pam is having a child with Jim. The great salesman. I love the great salesman. Here's my take on that line. I think Angela is actually trying to be nice. She is. She's, this is her, her passive aggressive way of trying to give Pam a compliment. Yes. Oh, okay. I have one background catch in this talking head. What is it? Did you notice that Angela's fingernails are bright red? No. When has she ever had on red nail polish? Oh. Ever. This is like some real spicy stuff. Well, I went in my digital clutter and the week we filmed this
斯克兰顿怎么了？安娜说，安吉拉，我想知道是谁想出了让你的角色怀孕的主意，编剧们和你谈过这件事，还是你在剧本围读时才感到惊讶？我认为安吉拉嫁给参议员对她的角色来说是一个非常有趣的发展，你把她情感之旅演得太棒了。我确实觉得很有趣，她为了报复和安迪约会，但现在她和参议员在一起，情况似乎不同了。你认为她是真的爱参议员，还是她只是相信自己爱他，而其实她的心一直属于德怀特？好吧，安娜，非常感谢你深思熟虑的问题。他们没有告诉我怀孕的事。我在一次剧本围读时发现了这件事，我只记得自己很高兴，因为这是一个新东西可以演。我们扮演这些角色已经有一段时间了，任何时候你给他们增加一个新的层面，作为演员都会让人非常兴奋。
episode, I was also filming struck by lightning. Oh, wow. And I was going back and forth between the two sets this week and my character on struck by lightning had fingernail polish and this big updo and I emailed you, Jenna, because I said this, I can't believe on one day I wear a fake belly and then I go to the next set and I wear a fake butt. This whole week has been fake belly, fake butt, fake belly, fake butt because my character on struck by lightning, the director wanted her to have kind of a big derriere and they had a padded butt suit I had to put on. Is this crazy? You spent so much time in those wetsuit padded outfit. Yes, it was a very funny week for me because I was going back and forth, but I guess for this talking head, I forgot to take the nail
至于安吉拉、德怀特和参议员，我一直认为安吉拉唯一的真爱永远是德怀特。我处理安吉拉与参议员约会然后结婚的方式是，安吉拉非常迷恋处于社会这个精英圈子的想法。这对她来说非常令人陶醉。非常令人陶醉。她喜欢地位。她喜欢德怀特在办公室的地位。她一直认为他应该成为经理。所以能有一个拥有大房子并且有头衔的人对她感兴趣，这也不失为对德怀特终极报复的一种方式，那就是她得以嫁给了一个每个人都认为非常合法的人。所以我想她爱的是做参议员妻子的想法，但我认为她从未真正爱过他，但她爱这一切的想法。是的，我懂。现在，安吉拉，我们也收到了很多关于我身体的邮件，关于我怀孕身体的邮件。大家都在说什么？
polish off. Well, we got a fan question for you, Angela from Anna asks in Scranton. What's up Scranton? Anna said, Angela, I was wondering who came up with the idea for your character to be pregnant and did the writers talk to you about it or were you just surprised at the table read? I think Angela marrying the senator was such an interesting development for her character and you do such an amazing job portraying her emotional journey. I do find it very interesting that she revenge dated Andy, but now that she's with the senator, it seems different. Do you think that she really loved the senator or was she just believing that she loved him and all the time her heart belonged to Dwight? Well, Anna, thank you so much for your thoughtful questions. They did not tell
首先，我要说的是，当我们开始拍摄这一季时，我大约怀孕八个月了。是的。在这部重温中，当我看到镜头前的自己时，我想，哦，天哪，我当时就是一个真正的孕妇。我感到非常自豪。我想，看看我。我突然意识到。我在电视或电影中没怎么见过这个。确实如此。他们经常隐藏怀孕。他们隐藏了我的。是的。所以你看到的只是我的头从东西上面冒出来，或者我前面有一个巨大的包。但对你来说，这一季，你展示了你真实的身体经历怀孕，经历你的最后三个月。是的。好吧，我有三个粉丝提问要分享。所以第一个来自不列颠哥伦比亚省的谢伊·J，她想知道，是否有关于试图在这一季隐藏我怀孕的讨论？
me about the pregnancy. I found out about it at a table read and I just remember being so delighted because it was just a new thing to play. We'd been playing these characters for a while now and anytime you got a new layer to them, it was really exciting as an actor. And as far as Angela and Dwight and the senator, I always believed that Angela's one true love was Dwight always. And the way I approached Angela dating and then marrying the senator was that Angela was very enamored with the idea of being in this sort of elite circle in society. That was very intoxicating for her. Very intoxicating. She loved status. She loved Dwight's status in the office. She always thought he should be the manager. And so then to have someone who
我一告诉保罗和格雷格我怀孕了，他们就问是否可以把它写进节目中。他们觉得时机正好。然而，我并没有轻率地做出这个决定。我等了很长时间才分享我的怀孕消息。我有过近亲在怀孕后期失去孩子的经历。这就像是一种悲伤。我知道。我姐姐，我知道。是的，所以把这样的事情公之于众是非常可怕的，因为如果真的出了什么问题，上帝保佑，然后你不得不继续扮演一个不再怀孕的人，这是一个可怕且非常脆弱的处境。我问保罗，我说，如果我们把怀孕写进节目里，如果发生了什么，帕姆也会发生什么吗？还是我得去上班然后穿上假肚子？就像我不想，我，你知道的。是的。所以莉和我讨论了很长时间。
had the nice big house and had the title be interested in her, that wasn't a way her ultimate revenge to Dwight as well, is that she got to marry someone she thought everyone thought was very legitimate. So I think she was in love with the idea of being a senator's wife, but I don't think she ever truly loved him, but she loved the idea of it all. Yeah, I get that. Now, Angela, we also got a lot of mail about my body, about my pregnant body. What were folks saying? First of all, let me say I was about eight months pregnant when we started shooting this season. Yeah. And in this rewatch when I saw myself on camera, I was like, oh my gosh, I was a real pregnant lady right there. And I felt really proud. I was like, look at me.
最终，我们决定，虽然这在怀孕中总是一种可能，但并非所有我的超声波检查都指向一个不会涉及任何问题的怀孕。是的，你有一个健康的怀孕。我是。所以我们同意把它写进节目中，但这是一个巨大的考量和重要的讨论，谢伊。我想说，我真的很感谢保罗和格雷格在那场讨论中的体贴。接下来我们有一个来自加利福尼亚州的粉丝提问，汉娜·L说，我现在怀着我的第二个孩子，预产期在九月。这次怀孕期间我的身体形象一直起伏不定，就像许多女性一样。我想知道在镜头前怀孕是什么感觉？我怎么强调都不为过，我有多喜欢在节目中看到帕姆的第二次怀孕，因为这当然看起来像是真实而准确的再现。顺便说一句，我知道怀孕并做着繁重的工作很难，特别是长时间工作。
It occurred to me. I haven't seen a lot of that on TV or in movies. It's true. They often hide pregnancies. They hid mine. Yes. So all you ever saw was my head popping over things or a giant bag in front of me. But for you in this season, you were showing your actual body going through pregnancy and going through your final trimester. Yes. Well, I got three fan questions to share about it. So the first one is from Shay J and British Columbia who wanted to know, was there any conversation about attempting to hide my pregnancy for this season? As soon as I told Paul and Greg that I was pregnant, they asked if they could write it into the show. They thought the timing was right. I did not take this decision lightly, however. I had waited a very long time
所以我只想代表许多职业妈妈说，我们看到你了。谢谢你，汉娜。然后来自德克萨斯州的海莉·O说，在经历了20多岁时的四次怀孕和产后饮食失调以及饮食失调恢复后，我喜欢帕姆看起来像一个真正的孕妇。并不是说她们不能看起来很小，只是它并不总是打包在子宫所在的完美小区域里。怀孕可以有各种形状和大小。我曾经对其他孕妇如何能保持苗条除了可爱的蓝色小肿块之外耿耿于怀，而我看起来到处都很大。这让我的饮食失调很难处理，恢复几乎不可能。但即便在开始饮食失调恢复七年后的今天，当我看到大孕妇时，我还是会流泪。我喜欢安吉拉对体型的刻薄，因为它在某种程度上展示了社会认为孕妇应该有的样子。但并不是每个人都一样。这太真实了。
to share my pregnancy news. I have had close family members lose pregnancies in the later stages of their pregnancy. And it is like a grief. I know. My sister, I know. Yes. So it's very, it's very scary to put something out there like that because if something does go wrong, God forbid, and then you have to continue playing someone pregnant when you no longer are, it's a terrifying and very vulnerable place to put yourself in. And I asked Paul, I said, if we write the pregnancy into the show and something happened, would something happen to Pam too? Or would I have to go to work and put on some fake belly? Like I don't, I like, I just, you know. Yeah. So Lee and I talked about it for a long time. And ultimately, we decided that while
海莉，我不能把这个话说得更好了。是的，安吉拉，在我的MySpace博客里，我也写了这个。哦，让我们听听。我是这么说的。当挺着大肚子工作时，这真是一次相当大的冒险。为了在我生孩子之前尽可能多地拍摄集数，我们一直在努力工作。这基本上意味着我一直在工作到预产期
that is always a possibility in pregnancy, it is not a probability that all of my ultrasounds were pointing toward a pregnancy that was not going to involve any problems. Yeah, you were having a healthy pregnancy. I was. So we agreed to write it into the show, but that was a big consideration and a big conversation, Shay. And I want to say that I really appreciated Paul and Greg's thoughtfulness in that conversation. So next we had a fan question from Hannah L in California who said, I am pregnant with my second child right now in due in September. My body image has been so up and down during this pregnancy as it is for so many women. And I would like to know what was it like for you to be pregnant on camera? I cannot emphasize enough how much I love seeing Pam's
这在怀孕期间总是可能的，虽然并非所有超声波都表明我的怀孕会出现任何问题。是的，你当时怀的是一个健康的健康宝宝。我是。所以我们同意把它写进剧本里，但这是一个巨大的考量，也是一次意义重大的对话，谢伊。我想说，我真的很感激保罗和格雷格在那个对话中表现出的体贴。接下来是来自加利福尼亚州的粉丝汉娜·L提出的问题，她说：“我目前怀着我的第二胎，预产期在九月。在这段怀孕期间，我的身材焦虑起伏不定，许多女性也是如此。我想知道，在镜头前怀孕是什么感觉？我怎么强调都不为过，我有多么喜欢看帕姆
second pregnancy on the show because it, of course, seems like such a real and accurate representation. As an aside, I know it can be hard to be pregnant and working a demanding job, especially with long hours. So I just want to say on behalf of so many working moms, we see you. Thank you, Hannah. And then Haley O from Texas said, having dealt with eating disorders and eating disorder recovery during four pregnancies and postpartum during my 20s, I love how Pam looks like a real pregnant woman. Not that they can't look small, but it's just not all packaged in a perfect little area where the womb is all the time. Pregnancy can come in all shapes and sizes. I used to have a hang up about how other pregnant women could stay tiny except for their
在剧中的第二次怀孕，因为这当然看起来是如此真实和准确的展现。顺便说一句，我知道怀孕还要应付繁重的工作是很不容易的，尤其是还要工作很长时间。所以我只想代表广大职场妈妈说一句，我们理解你的不易。谢谢你，汉娜。接着是来自德克萨斯州的海莉·O提出的问题：“在20多岁的四次怀孕和产后期间，我一直在与进食障碍及进食障碍康复作斗争，我特别喜欢帕姆看起来就像一个真正的孕妇。并不是说她们不能看起来娇小，只是并不是所有人的孕肚都总是完美地收在那么一小块地方。怀孕可以有各种不同的体型和尺寸。我过去总是纠结于为什么其他孕妇除了
cute little bump, whereas I kind of looked big all over. It made my eating disorder so difficult to deal with and recovery nearly impossible. But still to the stay seven years after starting ED recovery, when I see big pregs, it makes me tear up. I love how Angela is snide about the sizes because it does show in a way how society thinks pregnant women should be. But not everybody is the same. That is so true. Haley, I could not have soapboxed that better. Yeah. And Angela, in my MySpace blog, I wrote about this as well. Oh, let's hear it. I said this. It has been quite an adventure while working while so very pregnant. We've been working hard to shoot as many episodes as possible before I give birth. And that has basically meant that I'm working up until my due
可爱的小孕肚之外还能保持纤细，而我看起来全身都胖乎乎的。这让我的进食障碍变得极难处理，康复几乎成为不可能。但直到开始进食障碍康复七年后的今天，当我看到身材比较圆润的孕妇时，我还是会感动得落泪。我很喜欢安吉拉对身材大小冷嘲热讽的表现，因为这在某种程度上展现了社会对孕妇应有身材的刻板印象。但并不是每个人都一样。确实如此。海莉，我自己也说不出比这更好、更有说服力的话了。是的。而且安吉拉，在我的MySpace博客上，我也写过关于这个的内容。哦，让我们听听。我是这么说的：‘在身怀六甲的同时还要工作，真是一场相当精彩的冒险。为了在我生孩子之前尽可能多地拍完几集，我们一直在努力工作。这基本上意味着我一直工作到预产期临近’
date. Luckily, I feel great. I've been very fortunate. I haven't had much pain at all, which I credit to my twice weekly weight training and nightly walks with my husband. I think I had a pretty moderate pregnancy philosophy. I didn't starve myself. I didn't eat only organic greens and salads, but I was aware of what I put in my body and I tried to make mostly healthy choices. By the way, it's good to gain weight during pregnancy. And I mean more than the Hollywood 15 pounds. Not only does your body need to create a base for carrying around that giant belly, you need a reserve for when you begin breastfeeding. It all makes sense and works in harmony. That's not to say that I've always loved this process. It is a hard day when you look down
and see cellulite on your shins. I remember that day, Angela. I remember I think I texted you about it. I was like, really? My shins? No, I remember you actually showing me. I was like, wow. But here's what I wrote. I said it was one of those moments where I thought, yep, I'm really a mom now. This is just the first in a long list of things I'm going to do for my kid. So hang in there, ladies. We're all in this together. That's great. I love that you wrote that. Yeah, it was really great because it took me back to my mindset at the time. And I gained a lot of weight in that pregnancy. I was starving all the time. And I don't mean like hungry or like, oh, it's an hour past dinner time. I'm hungry. I mean, like I had a visceral hunger that could not be quenched. And
it wanted carbs. That is what it wanted. That was with my first. With my daughter, I wanted crisp cold vegetables. They could not be colder. They could not be crisper. I just wanted peanut butter. I wanted strawberries. I remember just eating giant bowls of strawberries all the time. Here's the thing, you guys, I really appreciate that you wrote that, Jenna, because we both worked right up into our due dates. Many women do. And what you have to navigate in a day, especially in your last trimester, you're doing all the things everyone else is doing, but you're also growing a baby. Yeah. And so it is wonderful when people write in and say the things like what Hailey said and Hannah said, because it feels good that we all see
each other and that we all recognize what we do for our children. And lovingly so, happy to do it. But at the same time, folks, if you are out there and your coworker is very pregnant, be nice to her. Yeah. Exactly. And speaking of that, Angela, I did write my MySpace blog. The cast and crew has been so kind. They've taken such good care of me. I have to imagine it's been good for our little guy to be around so much love and laughter each day. Yeah. And I did think that. I think I get to go to work and this little guy is just feeling me laugh so hard all day. I know. I thought that too, especially in dinner party when I was so pregnant. I'm like, Isabelle is in there. Your mom is laughing her butt off. Yeah. All right. That was a little bit
of a long tangent, but I think an important one. Yes. We're still in the cold open. We are. Where are we? Okay. Here we are. Jim and Daryl are trying to help Dwight move Kevin. Go to two minutes and 38 seconds. Leslie David Baker is completely cracking up. He is. Totally busted. I want to share with you guys something from the shooting draft. It's also in the deleted scenes on the DVD. Jim turns to Ryan for help. He says, Ryan, little help. And Ryan just looks at them and walks away. Wow. And then he has this talking head where he explains how trends make their way to Scranton. It's so funny. I'm going to put it in our stories. Okay. He holds up an elaborate map. I'm like, when did Ryan make this map? Why does he care so much about trends? And this is his
talking head. This is the way trends move across the country. They start in Japan. LA and New York pick it up soon after. Seattle looks at it and decides not to do it. Chicago gets it three months after that. Then it travels down the Mississippi. All the red states do it. Good morning. America does a piece about it. And then it shows up in Scranton. It's very funny because planking had been around for a while by the time it got to this episode. So that's pretty funny. Finally, Jim is going to say, you know what? No one should be planking. And Andy agrees and asked Dwight to take care of it. So Dwight walks around and basically starts pushing people off their planks violently. He drops things on their heads. He uses a fire extinguisher. We got a fan question
from Quinn T and Houston. How in the world did they do the planking scenes in the cold open? Were they stunt people? Especially for Kelly on the tall cabinet in Andy's office and Meredith falling off the bathroom stall wall. Those had to be stunt people, right? Well, everybody, I would normally go to Randy Cordray with this question. Yeah. But as we mentioned before, Randy moved on from the show after season seven. And our line producer for season eight and nine was Steve Burgess, who is a wonderful, delightful human being. We were so lucky. We had Ken Sabornak, then Randy Cordray, and then the amazing Steve Burgess. I know. Steve sends me an email for my birthday every year. Yeah, same. We're still in touch with him. We hit him up for details on
these stunts. And guess what? He wrote back and said it was all done by the actors. Yeah. He mentioned he thought Mindy did not love being up on the cabinet. He remembers that. But he said even Kevin, Meredith Toby, it was all done by the actors. He said they had to rehearse with our stunt coordinator, Wally Crowder on Tuesday. And then we shot them all on Friday. Well, I texted Kate Flannery about it. I was like, Kate, give me the dish on doing this planking stunt. And she sent us in an audio clip. Hey, that was me in the planking scene. Yeah, I planked on top of the stall of a men's room toilet. And they just had a couple mattresses on top of the toilet. It was kind of janky. And I kept thinking, I hope when rain uses the fire extinguisher that I go
the right way, because if I felt I felt the wrong way, I would have hit the ground. Risky, risky, risky. But I guess, you know, at that point, I really felt like a pro. Watching it now, I I could have gone bad fast. I can't believe it, actually, they had a mattress over the toilet. Is that the toilet that maybe Warren Buffett peed in? Okay, well, you gotta stop. I don't want to think about Warren Buffett. I don't want to think about Warren Buffett peeing in our prop toilet. But yes, probably. I mean, also Jenna, in the script, more people were planking. In the shooting draft, Gabe is going to enter for the day and Hank is planking at the reception couch. Hank? Hank. Gabe looks at him and says planking, amazing, relevant.
He then takes a picture of Hank, letting go of a large suitcase which falls over. Then there was a Gabe talking head explaining why he had returned. It's in deleted scenes. Let's hear it. Good morning. Corporate wants me up here. Dunder Mifflin wants me down there. What they worked out is Monday, Wednesday, and Friday, I'm here in Scranton. Tuesday, Thursday, I'm in Tallahassee. I mean, I feel like Vera Farmiga in up in the air, you know, more money, more problems, although I didn't get a raise. So, you know, same money, more problems. Oh my God, I want a mug that says same money, more problems. That is, that is really funny. So, he's just like taking the red eye every other day. He's just flying back and forth. Oh, you know,
I wish that that talking head would have stayed in because when I saw him pop up in later scenes, I was confused. Right? You're like, wait, Gabe left. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, that should have stayed in. Pretty much no one wants to work with Gabe. So, they just kept sitting back and forth. Did you notice the new opening credits, Angela? I did. Andy is going to place what looks like to be like a boat captain statue. Yeah, like a wooden sailor guy. Yeah. But it falls off his desk when he's adjusting it, which I thought was kind of amazing. Yeah. And James Spader is up there in the credits as well. Yeah. Well, I know this is unusual since we've only gotten through the cold open at this point, but I think we should take a break. I need to use the restroom. Same. And
then we'll come back and we'll do the rest of the episode. Maybe I'll plank. Is this one you're going to plank? After IP. Okay. Some interesting things happened during our break. Yes, they did. Let me just share one. Ellie Kemper texted us back. I'm going to read what she said. Ladies, it breaks my heart to have to choose between you two, but Ange is absolutely right. Three exclamation points. There is no way in all caps I was planking directly on that hard concrete. I am certain there was some sort of pad. I'm strong, but not that strong. Ha-ha! Yes. I knew it. All right. I stand corrected and it does make sense to me now. It makes sense to me that she did not have her forehead on a hard piece of concrete. Of course. Yes, lady. I mean upon
reflection for just two seconds. Of course. Of course. Also during the break though, speaking of planking, Angela did plank. I did plank. I was a little confused what planking was. I kind of forgot. Remember, I was like, how do I do this? But then Sam and Cassie found a little green chair where they sit in sound mix and I planked on it. Very well. You planked very well. Thank you. You held it for a long time. I did because you were like, I'm going to take a picture and now I'm going to come over here. I was like, I'm done. Get me off this chair. All right. Well, we are back and this is going to start a Pam runner. A very weepy Pam runner where she's watching this commercial. I guess she's been watching it over and over about a dog and he's trying to protect his bone and
everything about it makes her cry. This was a real commercial. I remember this commercial. Commercial was it? I feel like it was for like an insurance company and it's just this dog and he just is like he keeps moving his bone from place to place because he doesn't know like the safest place for it. Oh my gosh. I can't remember what it was like for a bank. Maybe he eventually puts his bone in the bank. Maybe it was for a bank, but it was a real commercial. I was actually watching it. Now Robert California is going to arrive, the new CEO and I love Jim's talking head where he says that Robert California will pick someone and zero in on them and then have a super intense small talk. That is such a great character trait. Yes. I just, I can imagine working with someone like
that and being like, oh no, oh no. Well, he's going to lock in on Erin. I love under her breath. She's like, here we go. Yeah. Okay. And I also love their exchange where he asks her how her day is going and she starts by saying, well, I woke up and he interrupts her. Yeah. He says, you don't need to say that, Erin. Yeah. Everybody wakes up, Erin. Yeah. Since the dawn of time it's been happening. So then she says, suddenly I was awake. I know. I know. Andy interrupts this chit chat with Erin to remind Robert that they had a meeting scheduled and Andy's going to have a talking head where he says he has to talk to Robert about some important stuff. And one of those things is that he wants everybody to get their extra long Columbus day weekend. Well, guess what? Robert
California, when he goes to talk to Andy leaves his notebook, his spiral notebook that he walks around with jotting things down in and he leaves it open at front reception and Erin sees it and there's a list. There's two columns with the line down the middle and everyone's names on either side. We had a fan catch from Evan D and Buffalo, New York, who said at six minutes and 20 seconds, you can see all the names on Robert's list. And instead of Creed's name being there, it just says old man. Yeah, I saw that. So that detail was in the script, Evan, as was that little waving standoff between Jim and Pam. That was scripted. And I love doing that moment. I was so excited about that. Well, here is how the list breaks down. On the left side, we have Jim Dwight, Andy
Darrell, Oscar Toby, Phyllis, Angela, Kevin. Also, someone has been erased. Did you notice that? Yes. There's a spot. On the right side, we have Stanley Gabe, Kelly, Ryan, old man, Pam, Meredith, Erin, and two spots have been erased. I noticed. There's been some moving of names. There's been some movement. This has the office all abuzz. Everyone's starting to talk about it. Dwight, Phyllis, Stanley, they want to know what's up. Pam runs over to the copier to make a copy of it. And Kevin says, we need a warning signal. If Robert's coming and Jim is like, we do not need a warning. Warning, warning, warning. And then they all go to their spots. I want you guys to know there were alts for this warning noise. There were. Oh yeah. I can't wait.
Per the shooting draft, here were the candy bag alts for this warning noise. As scripted, it was warning, warning. Alts were bap, bap, bap, bap. Another alt. Signal, signal. Another alt. Alert, alert. And another alt. Oh yes, we do. I don't know. That's how it's written. One more. Another one. And lastly, I really think warning was the best choice. I do too. Although maybe a submarine going under would have been good too. Well, by time, Phyllis is going to flip back in her chair to create a distraction. I mean, feet up in the air with the little mid-calf pantyhose. I know. Fan question from Jennifer Pee in Staten Island, New York. I can't help but notice how hard Phyllis seems to fall. Was there a mat behind her to
cushion the fall? Jennifer, there was a mat and that was not Phyllis. This was a stunt person. Yes. Oh, by the way, I don't know if you noticed. Very important catch. Seven minutes, 22 seconds. In all of this, may lay about the list. Did you notice that the reception sign is now glass? There is a glass- No. Etched reception sign now, this season. I did not. I don't know what that's about. I still regret not taking the reception sign. Yeah, that would have been a good steal. I know. Maybe we'll have to do one of those office-recreated tours. You know how they're going around the country and they're setting up the whole office. Oh, the experience and then I swipe it while I'm there? Yes. Would anyone arrest me for that? Come on. They better not.
Jim and Pam are going to bring the photocopied list of names to Andy and guess what? He wants no part of it. He's like, wait, this came out of Robert's notebook? I don't want to know. And they're really pressing him like, listen, you need to find out what this is about. It reminds Jim of some of the lists that Dwight used to make. So we cut to Dwight in Andy's office and he's got these old books of lists. So many lists. Yeah, he says, oh, let's see, let's compare it to this list. This is my list of if we were on a cruise ship and had to divide into lifeboats. This is if we were on a cruise ship and had to divide into rafts. Who would we eat in a live situation? Well, I want you to know, I remember this prop, these books of lists. They were amazing. There
were so many lists and there were even more lists that were scripted that we didn't get to hear. I found them in the shooting draft. Here they are. Dwight was also going to say, people I'd go inner tubing with, tents for a possible camping trip, people whose names also work for ponies, people with stronger top halves than lower halves, chicken fight pairing for a hypothetical pool party. Yeah, these were more of his lists. But I just remember thumbing through thumbing through that prop. That's a prop I wish I had. I wish rain had that. I can just hear the writer's room pitching these. They must have had so much fun. They must have wasted a whole night on those lists. I was very curious about why people make lists,
sort of the psychology behind it. And I found this quote, Jenna, and I thought you might appreciate it. According to psychologist and author, Dr. David Cohen, who loves lists, he put our love of to-do lists down to three reasons. Okay. One, they dampen anxiety about the chaos of life. That is 100% why I make lists. Two, they give a structure. Again, yes. And a plan that we can stick to. And finally, they are proof of what we have achieved for that day, week or month. These are all why I love lists. You do love a list. I keep a pad of paper on my desk, or sometimes I bring it with me in the morning to my morning coffee. And as I have things swirl in my head, I put it down on the list. And then later, I can look at the list and I can be like,
okay, what is the priority? How do I prioritize this? But now I'm not worried. I'm going to forget. It creates a sense of control over all the things swirling in my head all the time. Yeah. This article went on to say that lists can make you feel grounded, calm, and clear when you otherwise feel overwhelmed. Lastly, in looking up why people love to make lists, I did stumble across the origin of the word list in literature, the first time we see it used. When was it? William Shakespeare. Of course. In the first scene of Hamlet, Horatio says, Now, sir, young Fortenbrau of unimproved metal, hot, and full,
hath in the skirts of Norway here and there, sharked up a list of landless resolutes. Hmm. This led me to myshakespere.com. What a delight! It was wonderful and fascinating. First of all, they explained the list of landless resolutes, which many modern English speakers would think that the word list refers to the list of names of men who have signed on for the military campaign. But that was not the case with Shakespeare's audience. In this period, the word list had an entirely different meaning. It meant the border of a strip. Huh? Yeah. For example, a knight participating in a jousting match was said to be in the list. That meant he was inside the strip of land
marked off for combat. It also could mean a strip of clothing, a strip of parchment. But what Shakespeare did here for the very first time, using the word list, not to refer to a strip of parchment, but to refer to the words written on the parchment was the first time the word list was used in its modern thinking, which was a writing of series of items. So Shakespeare did mean a list as we know it today. Yes. But at the time, it normally meant border. Yes. Hmm. He reused the word. He reused it. Also, for those of you who are going to say to me that it was lawless resolutes in the original draft that Shakespeare wrote, it was landless resolutes. The youngest child who would have had no land, who would have had
motivation to go on this adventure. Guys, do not come for Angela on Shakespeare. All right? Do not. All of you, Shakespeare nerds out there, do not tell her that it was lawless resolutes. It was landless resolutes. It wasn't. It was a typo and it was printed lawless, which actually changed the meaning of those terms as well. Anyway, myshakespere.com for those of you that love Shakespeare, wonderful website. Angela, it has been a while since I have seen you so nerdy and excited about something. This is delightful to me. You are waving your arms about as you discuss this. Your glasses are on. Your glasses are off. Your passion behind this origin of the word list. Amazing. I love literature, you guys. I love literature and I love history.
Okay. Sorry, that was a tangent once again. Well, this is going to take us to Andy knocking on the conference room door. He is going to speak with Robert for a scene that I called so many papers, but no laptop. So many papers. Did you look at the conference room table? I know that's not what the scene is about, but like Robert, California, what are you doing? You're just reading like invoice sheets. What are you doing? And also you have like a couple of saber manual things. Yeah. I mean, what is the work you're doing in there? You don't need to return any emails as the CEO. You just review papers. It was an odd choice. I want to give Ed a little bit of love on how he entered the scene. In the shooting draft, it simply said interior
conference room later, Andy enters. But if you watch it, Ed enters and does a little bit of like a robot slash body wave dance move. Well, Andy tells Robert about the notebook being left open, shows in the photocopy. Robert can't believe that he photocopied the notebook. Andy immediately says it wasn't me. It was all of them. But everyone needs to know what this list is about. Robert claims that it was a doodle. Yeah. That some people draw houses or penises. Robert quote, unquote doodles names. Yeah, he likes to draw words and lists. Yeah. He says I might as well have been sketching a cube. Andy buys this. Yeah. Explanation. But the rest of the group is not convinced and they are now gathered in the bullpen. They have a giant easel with a blown up
piece of paper with this list on it. And they are still trying to figure out what do these two sides mean? Well, I have a question for you, Jenna. What is it? Do you think Robert left the planner for them to see on purpose? As like some kind of like, like social experiment? Right. I wouldn't be surprised. Well, then you would be thinking the way Ryan is thinking. This is from deleted scenes and you should hear it. It's all a mind game. He wanted us to see the list. He's a genius. Oh, yeah, I can see that. Right? Yeah. Well, now Toby is going to weigh in on the list. We haven't really heard from him this episode. Here's what he says. Guys, really, it's okay. Everyone has made a really solid first impression and I don't think there's any reason for anybody
to worry. I am on the wrong side and I am freaking out here. So he's so calm to the bullpen that he rounds the corner for this talking head and he is freaking out. Dwight's going to have everyone line up and face off. It's getting crazy. And then Robert enters and of course Kevin is like, warning, warning. And Robert is going to invite the left side of the list to lunch. The left side of the list minus Andy. Oh, yeah. He's been moved. So at the restaurant, I remember shooting these scenes. We had one big huge table and it was actually much longer than what you see. Some of it's in deleted scenes. Basically, everyone just parrots whatever Robert says. So when he asked Jim about Sesame Street and Jim says, CC loves Elmo and then Robert talks
about the cultural ghetto. Everyone agrees, right? This continued in the extended scenes that are on the DVD. The waiter comes over and takes Jim's order first and Robert says, I like that. I'll have it too. And then every single person gets the same order. It's chicken parmesan. Even Angela Martin, who's the vegetarian except for Dwight. He gets a steak. This is a total side note tangent. But during this scene when they're talking about Sesame Street, it made me realize I just read an article. Do you know Cookie Monster's first name? No, Sid. Sid? Sid. There's a song that he sings. It's a flashback to his youth from when Cookie Monster ate his first cookie. And in the song, his mom refers to him as Sid. His name is Sid. Cookie Monster. I don't
know. Just if anybody else wants that useless fact in their head. There you go. Bust that out at your next cocktail party. I will say, Toby is going to say, you know what? I'm going to go. I wasn't supposed to be here. I'm going to go. He kind of melts down. Yeah. There was a deleted talking head where Toby says that he thinks Robert is taking them all out to lunch to fire them. And that's why he bails. Oh, I did a little breakdown of what everyone is having to drink at the table. There are three people having alcohol. Robert is having a beer with his lunch. Oscar is having a glass of red wine and Phyllis is having a strawberry daiquiri. And Steve Burgess let me know that we filmed this at the hamburger hamlet now closed in Van
Ice. Back in Dunder Mifflin, nobody is excited about this pizza party. There's a lot of debate about whether or not a margarita pizza is going to be good. Pam is maybe going to cry. Fan catch from Heather F in California. What is Kelly doing at Jim's desk around 13 minutes? Cameron C also from California said, why is Kelly going through Jim's desk and why is Pam letting it happen? I remember the spit. This was not scripted. This was just something that Mindy improvised on the day. And you guys, Pam is just, she's in her feelings right now. She is. She's going to just let Kelly snoop. Finally, the pizzas arrive and Pam gets a kind of vague text from Jim while everyone else in the office gets a text from Kevin that reads suck it losers. Yeah.
Yeah. Back at the restaurant. This is because Robert basically said, I think of you guys as winners and the rest of the group as losers. So it's out there. It's out there in deleted scenes when the quote winners are leaving the restaurant. Dwight has gotten a bottle of champagne and is spraying everyone in the parking lot to celebrate. And Jenna, as he's doing this, I'm walking in the back with Phyllis and you can see that giant beetle thing is decided to attack me. What again? Yes. And I'm swatting at it and I yell like actually like in the take. I go, ah, and it's in the background of the scene. I'm going to have to put it in stories because proof of giant bug. Yes. Proof of bug. There it is. That stalked you the whole nine years of the
office. I think thought I was like a tiny yellow flower. Well, when they get back to the office, it's awkward to say the least. The winners start bullying the losers. It's super not cool. Kevin is spraying Meredith with a water gun while she's trying to, I think, tell her son how to put a casserole in the oven. Yeah. Why is her son home in the middle of the day and why are they making the casserole now? Well, many questions. Eventually, Andy's going to ask Robert to come out in the bullpen and kind of clarify this sort of top tier, second tier sort of thing. And Robert's like, I never said that. That's not what I said. Andy's like, thank you. And then Robert says, I said winners and losers. And Andy's like, oh, oh, okay, then that would be what we're
talking about. And then Robert goes on this amazing monologue about his philosophy behind managing people, which is that he believes in both positive and negative reinforcement. He thinks you shouldn't sit around and wonder what a person thinks about you. He's going to let you know. And he thinks these people are winners. He thinks the other people are losers. But he says, you know what? I haven't known you all for that long. Losers prove me wrong. Winners prove me right. And everyone's like, oh, so maybe it was intentional, lady. Maybe it was. Maybe Ryan is right. Well, Andy doesn't like this explanation. No, he can't let it go. He's going to march into the conference room and start just sharing with Robert about all
the attributes of the right side of the list. Yes. That Pam is not a loser. That Aaron is not a loser. Stanley has leads in sales and also two relationships. Yes. And guess what Robert says? I didn't know about the sales. Yes. So that means he knew about the two relationships. I thought that was a funny line. Andy is also going to demand the three and a half day weekend for Columbus Day. And Robert gives in. So Andy accomplished something for the group. Andy stood up for the group. He did. The day ends in a win for the new branch manager, Andy. On the way out, Pam is still watching her Weepy Dog video commercial. And Jim drops a little something on the ground. And Pam has a talking head. I remember shooting this. You're so good in it.
You made me tear up. Jim has made his own list. And on one side is Pam, Cece and the new baby. And on the other side, it says everything else. I know. And then Pam is like, I'm going to frame it. I can always unframe it. I love that. Am I being overly sentimental? I don't know. We had a fan question from Molly G and Cincinnati who wanted to know was that line, I'm going to frame it. I can always unframe it, improvised or scripted. It was scripted. And Chris C from Madison Heights, Virginia wanted to know whose handwriting was on the paper. And it was John's. He wrote that out. That was his handwriting. He has really good handwriting. Yeah. I mean, I think he might have taken some time
and care with it knowing it would be on camera, but they brought him a piece of paper and they said, write this down. Well, that was the list. We hope you enjoyed it. Are you going to make a list today? Maybe you will. If you do, you can thank William Shakespeare for that. A big thank you to Steve Burgess, B.J. Novak and Paul Lieberstein for letting me reach out to you about this episode and to Kate Flannery for sending in her audio clip about her stunt. Yes. And to Ellie for answering our voicemail that we left. You guys, our cast and crew are the absolute best. And thanks so much for listening and rewatching with us. We love you. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf,
而且小心翼翼地对待它，明知它会被拍进镜头，但他们拿给他一张纸，对他说，把这个写下来。好吧，这就是那个清单。我们希望你们喜欢它。你今天会列一张清单吗？也许你会的。如果你这样做了，你可以为此感谢威廉·莎士比亚。非常感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯、B.J.·诺瓦克和保罗·利伯斯坦让我能够就这一集联系你们，也感谢凯特·弗兰纳里发来关于她特技的音频剪辑。是的。还要感谢艾莉接听了我们留下的语音留言。你们大家，我们的演员和剧组绝对是最棒的。非常感谢你们和我们一起收听和重温。我们爱你们。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由 Earwolf 制作，
Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoke. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制片人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制片人是艾恩斯利·布比科克。我们的主题曲是里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。要获得 Stitcher Premium 的一个月免费试用，请使用代码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。